bei lichte besehen und von nahem
betrachtet haben die menschen an den
hebeln der macht und die menschen ohne
besondere macht oft dieselbe anliegen
und sorgen etwa wenn es in paris um
terror geht aber von den menschen mit
macht erwarten wir dass sie die großen
fragen der zeit lösen können und es hat
mich seit jeher schon beschäftigt wie
viel spielraum die mächtigen haben dinge
zu bewegen und probleme zu lösen zuerst
einmal sind das ja auch einfach leute
wie du und ich mit ihren ideen ihren
werten und mit ihrer ausbildung und
einen von ihnen derzeit in diesem hotel
in interlaken ist habe ich gekannt als
wir beide gleichzeitig an der uni genf
assistenten in politologie waren
josé manuel barroso wurde nach kurzer
zeit als folge von portugal eu
kommissionspräsident und stand als
solcher mit auf der brücke der
weltenlenker während zehn jahren und
hier am alpensymposium einem großen
polit und wirtschaftspresse treffe ich
ihn nieder und befrage ihn vor den 500
geladenen gästen und danach will ich
unter vier augen weiter nachhaken was
ihn in die politik trieb und wie es
hinter den kulissen der wahl zu gehen
dazu gekommen
weeks ago noch vor zehn wochen hatten
sie eines der spannendsten politischen
ämter der welt inne
leiden sie unter entzugserscheinungen
wie ein drogensüchtiger deckt allerdings
bereits gefiel diese aufgabe
andererseits denke ich zehn jahre sind
genug
jetzt fühle ich mich frei irgendwie ist
es besser denn ich habe mehr zeit zum
nachdenken
ich leide nicht unter diesem sogenannten
post office syndrom vielleicht noch
nicht nach gerade zwei monaten
aber man kann schon süchtig seiner
politik politik ja viele menschen sind
süchtig nach politik was ist es die
macher das ist eine gute frage
eine meiner erfahrungen in diesen jahren
ich habe ja wie sie in der anmoderation
erwähnt haben politikwissenschaften
studiert wenn ich mich in einer
bestimmten situation befand konnte ich
mich bei bedarf herausnehmen und von
außen gedacht was haben sie gesehen
ich verlor ein paar illusionen sahen sie
einen großen politiker
gleichzeitig habe ich meinen
enthusiasmus nicht verloren im grunde
genommen wollen die politiker die
politischen machthaber das beste für ihr
landgut verkehr könnten die arbeiten im
öffentlichen interesse
aber ich persönlich glaube dass mehr als
in anderen funktionen in der politik das
ego der eigennutz eine sehr große rolle
spielt was verständlich so bei den
andern oder auch bei ihnen
ich schließe mich mit 1 denn als
ernsthafter politiker will man
profitieren können
man will anerkannt werden man braucht
den applaus ein wenig wie ein künstler
man will spüren dass man unterstützt
wird und das ist manchmal ein problem